The SCP Foundation has dealt with its fair
share of superheroes - from the delightful
SCP-2800, the prickly Scottish vigilante known
as Cactusman, to the utterly tragic SCP-2241,
also known as the Superhero Wannabe.
But we couldn’t help but wonder: What if
the SCP Foundation went up against a truly
evil anomalous force that simply masqueraded
as a superhero?
And we couldn’t think of a character who
fits this bill better than Homelander from
The Boys, the hit TV series produced by our
arch-nemeses at Amazon.
Homelander is rotten to the core and has a
wide range of superpowers that allow him to
make his darkest desires a reality.
And that’s why today, we’re powering up
the Anom-O-Tron 6000, filling it with all
three current seasons of The Boys, and posing
the big question: Could the SCP Foundation
bring this sadistic supe to his knees, or
is he just too diabolical?
Let’s find out…
People love superheroes.
They love that warm, cozy feeling the Supes
give them.
A golden beacon of righteousness to swoop
out of the sky and save the day, so we don’t
have to do it ourselves.
But, you see, the thing about superheroes
is, they aren’t always nice.
If the whole world holds someone up on a pedestal,
makes them believe from a young age that they
can do no wrong, that they’re the ultimate
paragon of virtue, and that they have the
powers and freedom to do anything they want…
well, you end up with him.
The Homelander.
Now, some look to Homelander as a hero, and
why wouldn’t they?
He flies around saving people, wears those
distinctive stars and stripes on his back,
and stars in all those movies about how great
he is.
But that’s just a cover story, the publicly
acceptable story put out by Vought, the company
responsible for creating him in the first
place.
They’re there to sweep under the rug any
bad thing that Homelander – or any of their
so-called superheroes – has ever done, so
that nobody will ever figure out the truth.
And what is the truth?
Well, as far as Supes go, Homelander’s even
worse than the very worst of the worst.
He’s a murderous, self-absorbed, narcissistic
psychopath, with no empathy for powerless
human beings.
He thinks of himself as superior to the rest
of us, ordinary people are just expendable,
and he’ll gladly allow an entire plane full
of innocent civilians to die with little care
or remorse.
Oh, but Homelander will play all that up for
the cameras, though, which is why nobody would
ever think to question his status as a hero.
As far as the public knows, Homelander’s
actions are always justified, and that he
can do no wrong, and it’s that mentality
that allows him to carry on doing whatever
he wants with total impunity.
But what if everyone turned on Homelander?
Say his cover was finally blown and the rest
of the world got to see him as he really is:
a murderer with too much power, rampant insecurity,
an explosive temper, and some nasty lingering
parental issues.
Sure, getting a look at the real Homelander
might be a cause for celebration from his
most hardcore fanboys, allowing them to rally
behind what they think he stands for.
But what if we all had enough?
What if everybody rejected Homelander?
As it turns out, that might be the final straw
that breaks him.
By his own admission, Homelander would much
prefer to be loved by everyone.
But, if you take that away, he’s more than
happy to settle for being feared.
And with the level of power that he has – flight,
super strength, invulnerability, heat vision
– all it would take would be a show of his
abilities in order to incite fear.
And now, it’s happened.
The love anyone had for Homelander is gone,
maybe his crimes have finally been exposed,
or he might have laser visioned someone in
broad daylight.
Regardless of the spark that started it, the
fire has started burning, and now he’s no
longer chained, Homelander is free to do whatever
he wants.
He started tactically, taking out key structures
of influence in the United States.
The White House went first, the red-hot beams
of his eye lasers carving through the entire
building, separating staff and secret service
members at the waist or the neck, splattering
the walls with blood.
The ‘World’s Greatest Superhero’ took
care of the President personally, melting
him down with his heat vision before flying
away.
Next on his list of targets was the Pentagon,
shrugging off bullets and tank shells from
the United States Military as they were rapidly
deployed to stop him.
It didn’t take long for Homelander to cut
through the soldiers sent to stop him, before
demolishing the Pentagon with as little as
a supersonic clap of his hands.
As the building crumbled around him, so did
a number of the country’s defenses fall
as well.
But there was one last line of defense, one
organization that just might have access to
the means to bring the Only Man in the Sky
back down to group level.
The SCP Foundation were no strangers to powerful
beings running amok, but they were the only
ones with the means to oppose a rampage like
this.
Now, while Homelander had already decimated
much of the regular armed forces, the Foundation
brought an army of their own to bear.
Enter the Mobile Task Forces, the organization’s
most elite special operatives.
They’re specifically trained to deal with
threats well beyond the capabilities of the
regular military and can be quickly deployed
almost anywhere in the world at a moment’s
notice, ready for action.
Mobilizing their collected forces, the Foundation
dispatched its MTFs at once.
They had to be smart; Homelander was playing
this tactically, taking out centers of influence,
and defense capabilities, still unleashing
his years’ worth of bottled-up rage but
using it in a controlled, calculated way.
If they sent every Mobile Task Force to where
Homelander was, he could easily fly away at
supersonic speeds, outmaneuver them – or
just disintegrate the Foundation’s entire
reserve of troops in one move.
So, their primary goal was to divide and conquer,
and spread their MTFs across the country so
that anywhere Homelander went, they would
be waiting for him.
Of course, the fall of the regular military
had already shown that conventional weapons
had little to no effect on Homelander.
He is completely resistant to almost every
form of physical harm, not only completely
bulletproof, but unfazed by explosions as
well.
On top of that, his powers for detecting threats
were also unparalleled.
Homelander had the ability to see through
almost any solid object or surface using X-ray
vision; however, the Foundation knew there
was a limit to this ability, and that the
Supe couldn’t see through certain metals,
specifically zinc.
He also has tremendous olfactory and auditory
senses, well beyond that of any ordinary human
being, Homelander could detect changes in
smell on such an acute level that he could
detect changes to someone’s adrenaline levels,
as well as using that ability to detect explosives.
But it was his super hearing that the Foundation
was planning to exploit.
They knew Homelander’s senses were so attuned
he could detect changes in a person’s heartbeat,
enough to know when someone was lying.
However, having such a level of sensitive
hearing meant that Homelander had at least
one vulnerability: high-frequency soundwaves.
The Foundation knew it wouldn’t be enough
to kill the man in the sky, but they had another
trick up their sleeve for that.
First, they needed to draw him out, but how
would they when Homelander could easily overhear
the orders being broadcast to their troops?
Simple, they could lie.
The Foundation started issuing falsified directions
to its MTFs on the ground, each one followed
up with a written digital message via each
troop’s heads-up display.
All Foundation operatives were reminded to
disregard any radio communications, that these
weren’t real orders, merely just interference
to throw Homelander off what they were actually
doing.
While the fake radio orders were attempting
to nudge Homelander closer and closer towards
New York, which was where Vought Tower, his
headquarters, were located, one team was already
there, lying in wait.
Mobile Task Force Pi-1, also known by the
codename ‘City Slickers’, had received
a coded message from the Foundation.
They were instructed to infiltrate Vought
Tower, retrieve an item from the company’s
research and development labs, then make their
way to the roof.
Once they were there, the next stage of the
plan was to administer what they found in
R&D, then await an airdrop of high-frequency
sonic weaponry that the Foundation was sending
to aid them.
Storming Vought Tower had been the surprisingly
easy part.
The entire company had fallen into chaos;
now that their number one product was raining
death from the sky, the employees at Vought
didn’t seem to care much about their jobs
anymore.
The City Slickers had snuck into the laboratory
and found what they were sent for: Temporary
Compound V, a chemical that would alter human
biology and grant anyone superpowers for a
twenty-four-hour period.
It had the nasty side effect of turning the
user’s brain into Swiss cheese, but under
the circumstances, it seemed necessary.
Dosing themselves with it, all of the Slickers
were in agony as they felt the V24 burning
in their veins.
Just as the chopper was arriving to drop off
their weaponry, a loud, booming sound rang
out, shattering windows across the city as
Homelander’s approach broke the sound barrier.
The MTF stared up in horror as his laser vision
cut through the helicopter above their heads,
one of the crates landing on the roof as the
fiery wreck plummeted down towards the street.
“Jackson!”
the team leader yelled to one of his men,
before pausing.
He knew if he told him to retrieve the sonic
cannon, Homelander would destroy it in seconds.
Instead, Jackson watched as his commanding
officer leaped up into the air, hundreds of
feet higher than he would normally have been
capable of.
He careened towards a surprised Homelander,
swinging a Compound V-fuelled uppercut that
connected with his jaw, reeling him slightly
as he hovered above.
Taking that as their cue, the other members
of the City Slickers started attacking the
out-of-control Supe.
One of them was firing energy blasts from
his palms, and another had her arms stretching
out like rubber, grabbing the Homelander’s
cape in an attempt to drag him out of the
sky.
Meanwhile, Jackson was scrabbling across the
roof of the Tower, fumbling with the clasps
on the crate that contained the weapon.
He could hear snarling behind him, as Homelander
roared in disapproval, disgusted that these
so-called ‘ordinary people’ were daring
to attack him.
His heat vision burned through the City Slicker’s
uniforms, but couldn’t pierce their skin.
Enraged, Homelander gripped the commander’s
head as he made another jump towards, him,
pushing both his super-strong hands together
until he could hear the man’s skull beginning
to crack… then he kept squeezing.
Flattening the commander between his palms,
Homelander flew downwards, landing a dual-fisted
punch that burst through the chests of the
other two Slickers.
He pulled both hands back, his red gloves,
like the rest of his uniform, already slickened
with copious amounts of blood.
Then, a loud, shrieking sound pierced his
attuned ears as Jackson fired the sonic cannon.
The cacophony of high-frequency soundwaves
it emitted were deafening to Homelander’s
attuned, sensitive ears, sending pain shooting
through his head.
Unfortunately, pain meant little to Homelander,
and he could still function despite it.
It angered him even further that someone was
trying to best him, that they’d highlighted
and tried to exploit a weakness – something
the Supe had told himself he didn’t have.
He shot forwards lightning-fast, wrenching
the device out of Jackson’s hands before
gripping him by the throat, lifting him up
off his feet so he was dangling over the edge
of the tower.
“Who in the hell do you think you are?”
Homelander muttered, disturbingly subdued
despite the obvious, unhinged look in his
eyes.
“Just…”
Jackson gasped for breath as he felt fingers
clasping around his fault; in the distance
there was a low, rhythmic rumbling, like an
earthquake…
or heavy footsteps getting closer.
“Just a distraction.”
With that, Homelander’s hand closed tight,
the very second that Jackson teleported out
of his grip, leaving the Supe standing on
the roof alone, save for the bodies of the
other City Slickers.
He turned to face the sound of the oncoming
footsteps, detecting the sound of whirring
machinery along with it.
This was something new.
It was rare for Homelander to ever face a
real challenge.
Nothing ever forced him to improve his skills
in combat.
In most cases, he could just rely on his strength,
or bring a quick end to confrontations with
his eye lasers, which made the sight of SCP-5514
approaching all the more surprising to him.
Striding across the city like something out
of a Pacific Rim movie was a gigantic mech,
known as SCP-5514 or by its far cooler sounding
nickname The Dragonslayer.
Working with the Global Occult Coalition and
Hy-Brasil, the Foundation themselves constructed
SCP-5514, using various anomalous methods,
designing the machine to combat Large Scale
Aggressors, or LSAs.
While the Dragonslayer – like the name implies
– was built with fighting monsters and kaiju
similar to its own size, these desperate times
had called for desperate measures.
The mech’s huge, robotic arm hoisted its
primary weapon, a Cold Iron Sword; its blade
twenty meters long.
Inside, members of Mobile Task Force Eta-5,
the Jäeger Bombers, were piloting the Dragonslayer,
readying for battle with Homelander.
He was staying still, not attempting to run
or even fly away, instead, he stayed at the
top of Vought Tower.
It was like he was waiting, watching, unfazed
by the approaching humanoid machine, looking
right at it... or through it.
The Dragonslayer brought its Cold Iron Sword
swooping down through the air, the blade coming
right down on where Homelander stood.
It cleaved directly through the building beneath
him, carving Vought Tower in two, sending
a shower of glass and concrete over the plaza
below.
The Supe caught the blade as it came at him,
screaming in pain as he felt it cut into his
hands.
Any wound left by the Cold Iron Sword was
permanent, there was no regenerating or recovering
from it.
Homelander’s natural durability gave him
an edge, that and being so much smaller than
the sword itself, allowed him not to be sliced
to pieces.
But even touching it through his gloves hurt.
The Tower was rubble, Homelander was down,
but far from out.
He climbed up through the debris and bodies
he was buried under, not caring when he blasted
his heat vision through the dead and wounded
to clear a path back up.
Looming above, the Dragonslayer stood taller
than most buildings.
His eyes glowing both with anger and the red
light of his lasers, Homelander pushed himself
up off the ground and flew up into the air.
The mech’s arm moved weightlessly to swat
him out of the air, but Homelander used his
speed and momentum to shoot through the metal,
ripping through the machine’s hand before
it could land a strike.
Homelander started zipping out of the path
of the Dragonslayer as it opened fire with
its various anomalous armaments.
While the mech was primarily used for close-quarters
melee combat with various LSAs, it also featured
a number of longer-range weaponry.
Mounted on SCP-551’s shoulder was a Beowulf-Sigurd
Railgun, an anomalous weapon that could use
altered gravity to affect the weight of its
targets, causing projectiles to impact with
higher velocity.
Yet, none of these projectiles landed a shot,
unable to catch Homelander at his current
flight speed.
With every supersonic pass he made of the
Dragonslayer, the deranged Supe took another
look at his current enemy.
His X-ray eyes could penetrate most of the
metal and gave him a clear enough view of
what was inside.
There was a miniature sun powering it, kept
perpetually stable while it generated energy
for SCP-5514.
Surrounding it were sub-dimensional portals,
venting the excess heat off this plane of
reality so that the mech and nothing around
it melted.
A similar process was moving some of the substantial
weight of the mech into a tiny pocket dimension,
which had allowed it to move so swiftly without
being too cumbersome.
Piloting it were humans, more MTF operatives.
Spotting them through the metal hull, Homelander
flew towards the Dragonslayer like a bullet.
The force of the impact caused the mech to
wobble slightly as Homelander shot through
the outer layers of armor.
He came bursting out into the main chamber,
eyes burning intense lasers through the vital
inner components of the Dragonslayer.
The beams sliced the unprotected MTFs up,
reducing them to a bloody paste before Homelander
turned his rage towards the power source.
Ripping through more of the metalwork, he
looked at the housing for the sub-dimensional
portals venting out the mini sun’s heat.
Though he had a limited understanding of what
exactly this all was, Homelander could make
sense of what it was doing.
He fired off another series of blasts with
his heat beams, tearing through the devices
that regulated the portals, before flying
back out of the Dragonslayer as fast as he
could.
Landing at its feet, he looked up to see his
despicable handiwork.
From within, the sub-dimensional portals began
pulling the insides of SCP-5514 in different
directions, pulling it apart and sucking it
into different pocket dimensions as it collapsed
in on itself.
Homelander sighed, the tiniest hint of fatigue
he felt passing in a fleeting moment, gone
before the Dragonslayer eventually fell.
“Enough, cease this villainy!”
a voice called from nearby.
Homelander sighed in exasperation to face
this latest nuisance that dared oppose him.
When he saw the shadowy figure approaching
him, he was taken aback at first, thinking
he recognised who it was.
“Noir?” he asked in disbelief.
“No, that is not my name,” the dark-clad
figure announced.
“Homelander of the Seven, your time has
come!
For now, you face The Specter!”
The Specter, otherwise known as SCP-4494,
was the physical embodiment of crime fighting
itself.
Its long, dark cloak whipped in the wind,
a wide-brimmed hat pulled low, giving it the
appearance of a shadowy gunslinger.
From head to toe, The Specter seemed to pull
all light on the visible spectrum into itself,
making it look like a ghostly shadow come
to life.
“And how the hell do they expect you to
stop me?”
Homelander sneered.
“I go wherever injustice reigns,” The
Specter replied, not short on dramatic flair.
“And you have unleashed horrific, unspeakable
terror on the innocents of this world.
I will ask you once, and once only: stop this.
Walk away.”
Immediately, Homelander started laughing.
“Really?
That’s all you’ve got?” he scoffed.
“Just asking nicely?”
“You have lost your way,” SCP-4494 declared.
“All this destruction, and for what?
Just to display your power?
To subjugate, make people fear you?
Or are you still trying to win the approval
of a mother and father you never had?”
That last sentence struck a nerve with Homelander,
enough to make him zip forward, launching
a punch at The Specter.
His fist passed through a dark fog that took
the place of its intended target, as SCP-4494
dissipated and then reformed behind Homelander.
It put two shadowy arms around his neck, gripping
the maddened Supe in a headlock.
“You were made to be a hero,” The Specter
whispered.
“Look at how far you’ve fallen.”
Homelander angrily wrenched the arm away and
threw his captor over his head, only for the
Spectre to become mist again, surrounding
the hero in a thick, black cloud.
He fired his heat vision again, the beams
passing through the layer of fog without causing
any damage.
“It’s over, Homelander, no longer will
you terrorize the innocent,” came a booming,
dramatic voice from all angles.
“You are not the hero you think of yourself
as, but a villain.
This mistake stops here!”
“This isn’t a mistake.
I don't make mistakes!”
Homelander roared.
“I’m not like the rest of you, I’m stronger,
smarter.
I’m better.
I am better.
I’m the real hero!”
“Are you?”
echoed The Specter’s voice.
Something thin and papery landed at Homelander’s
feet, the fog dissipating again as the Spectre
stood before him.
Confused, Homelander picked up the papery
object, it was a comic book, the words ‘Action
Comics’ emblazoned on the top.
The cover showed a man dressed much like himself,
lifting an old green car above his head, his
red cape billowing in the win, a letter ‘S’
worn across his chest.
As he flicked through the pages, tears formed
in Homelander’s eyes.
“This is what you think you are,” The
Specter said solemnly.
“But look around, look at the lives you’ve
taken or ruined.
A hero?
No, heroism is not subjugating others.
Not viewing yourself as superior.
Heroism is realizing we are all the same,
and standing up to those that would try to
disagree.”
The Spectre brought his dark cloak around
Homelander’s shoulder.
There were no survivors around to see where
they went or to hear SCP-4494’s final words.
“You aren’t a real hero.”
And then they were gone…
Now, if you want to see another clash between
a comic book legend and one of the most infamously
dangerous anomalies, go and check out “DEADPOOL
VS SCP-682” to see the Merc with the Mouth
battling the Hard to Destroy Reptile.
Then after that, if you’re in the mood for
another chaotic match-up, witness the galaxy’s
greatest bounty hunter taking on the Flesh
that Hates in “BOBA FETT VS SCP-610”!